For this next section, we are going to be primarily focusing on lighting our scene as if we were on an actual stage.
Indoors, no exterior lights, very controlled lighting.
Now there are a couple things as we go about lighting this scene that I want you to keep in mind.
Some of these core principles.
The first one that I want to address is this idea of trying to add too much light or trying to add too many lights at once.
And balancing them all at the same time.
One of the approaches that I recommend the most when it comes to lighting is using more of an isolated approach.
And the idea basically behind this is add a light, adjust the values to where it looks fairly balanced.
Again, coupled with the fact that we've disabled auto exposure and we have essentially controlled the environment in which we're building our lights.
We can add those lights, adjust as needed, and then disable them temporarily.
Continue to add lights as necessary.
And then in the end, come back and balance all of those lights together.
Ideally, this is going to avoid us adding so many lights that things get either too bright or too dark.
And then we're essentially running circles around adjusting light values, coloration, et cetera, over and over and over again.
So for this particular section, we're going to disable all of our lighting except the skylight.
We are going to create our light stage.
Again, I've got some things within the collections parameter that you can use to make this process easier.
And again, using that isolation approach, we're going to add our lights, adjust values, disable those lights and then move on to the next light.
And then finally, and turn all of them on and then balance them just with their intensities as needed.
Now, one of the recommendations that I do have when it comes to building your lighting is, again,
because we're trying to adhere to more realistic values, is using something that does have a real world counterpart, such as candelas or lumens.
I'll show you how to do that.
And then finally, the last thing, because we are using Unreal Engine 5, we're going to be using fully dynamic lighting, meaning we don't have to bake our lighting.
So we want to make sure that any light that we add to our scene is set to movable.
So to start, we want to open up our zero one neutral level, which is going to be in our content classrooms walkthrough.
And within this particular map, we've added some different callouts just to show you the things that we have changed or how we've gotten to this point.
Now, again, all of these bridge off of what we had just talked about.
So, for example, if I select our PPV neutral, which is our post processing volume, neutralize the light and then we can add some more light.
So we're going to go ahead and select our post processing volume neutralizer.
You'll see here we have our bloom disabled, our exposure compensation set, Minimax CV.
Now, one thing to note is as you're working with this, you can.
So, for example, this one is calibrated.
The exposure compensation, if you adjust this up or down to make it brighter, that's not necessarily bad.
But again, we use our tools to make sure we stay within value.
So you can see that even though it looked brighter, if I adjust this, you'll see that I've clearly blown out the upper range of my values.
So, again, I'll set this back to negative five point five and we're looking pretty good.
So with our directional light, you can see here that we have some values here.
For example, our sunrise, typical overcast day, bright sunlight, brightest sunlight.
You can see where we have that correlation with our lux.
So, again, I could also check we don't have the lights in here.
So we can change this value again from using unit lists, deluxe or candelas.
We'll change that in a little bit.
And the same thing here, we have some correlations to again, some real world counterparts.
So, for example, a hundred watt bulb incandescent bulb is going to be roughly around sixteen hundred lumens.
All right. So to get started, I'm going to select my directional light.
I'm going to go ahead and just turn off the effects world.
So this should be disabled.
I'm going to use my skylight to make sure that this is still enabled.
We're unmovable. This should still be the same.
Our cube map and our source type. You see this is fairly good.
Again, with intensity scale, if I were to bump this up to say something like three hundred.
Again, just be very careful with this because this is the only light in our scene.
We don't necessarily want to adjust this too much right now.